hey everybody it's Mike from order flows
and I'm shooting this quick video you
know because a few people have asked me
how to set up uh the order flows Delta
scalper indicator in markers okay so the
order flows Delta scalper runs on
ninjatrader 8 as well as markers markers
is a tool from uh Pablo at the indicator
store that will allow you to automate
the trading aspect of using the Delta
scalper okay so let's uh let's jump in
so first thing you got to do obviously
is um you know you want to open a chart
and you're going to add the indicator
and add markers so let's uh go through
the steps here it's really very simple
if you're familiar with markers you
understand what you need to do but for
people that are new to markers you know
this is a nice quick video on how to get
started so what you're going to do is
you're going to add the indicator set
the settings you know how you like it so
I'm going to add the order flows Delta
scalper first then I'm gonna go to the
folder with Mark markers and I'm going
to add markers plus the force I'm going
to add copy one for a copy for the buys
one for the cells because I'm going to
use the fast copy and markers all right
so you should have the Delta scalper
you're going to have markers plus the
force markers copy one for the buys one
for the cells all right so let's go and
set up markers
alrighty so what I'm going to do is I'm
going to go in and set up the automation
part so the
type of order it's going to be a day
order and I'm going to
enable Longs enables shorts and fast
signals because I'm going to be using
the fast signals mode okay and for fast
signals it's going to be called Longs
right your buy signals I'm going to call
my cell signals shorts
okay and let's show you how what that
means in a minute
um now you could show the p l if you
want max daily loss max daily profit you
know set it at a thousand
um you know I'm using the mes so it's uh
you know a thousand either way is is you
know quite big moves you don't really
need to change anything else in here
okay
um I'll talk about later about the ATM
and you know make sure the account is
set so let's set up the buys and the
cells so the first one markers copy
um this is gonna be called long so I'm
going to change the markers the new
markers variable from my line to Longs
okay I'm going to enable fast signal
okay I want to change the setup
calculate on each tick
and I'm going to change you know how
it's plotted
um
for Buys so it's going to be blue solid
this is a buy it's going to be a
triangle up and I like to make it a
little bit big I keep this the same as
what I use for the indicator in there so
it's which is uh buys our blue solid
triangle up now the most important
setting is this one the data Series
right it says in this case it says mes
but you have to change the input series
you have to change it to the indicator
so you got to go in here you click on
right so here I'll just show you that
real quick you click on this box edit
input right and pulls this up find the
indicator right order flows Delta
scalper now again set it to the settings
that you prefer okay because this is
just going to be the default settings
um it's going to plot the positive Delta
change okay positive Delta change is for
Buys so click ok
and that one is set up now for the cells
and cells are the name is shorts
enable fast signal use fast signal
change the setup calculate on each tick
and I'm going to change the plots from
Blue since it's cell uh
this is cells so it's going to be red
solid triangle down
okay
change the size to eight and I gotta set
up the data series the input series okay
so open that up click on the indicator
go in here to Delta scalper okay change
the settings you like so I can change
that to look back to zero and here the
plot right positive Delta that's where
the buys negative Delta change is for
the cells Okay click OK right so that's
it basically so shorts
okay Longs this is all set up in here
lungs for buys shorts for cells click
apply
okay now you can see all the stuff gets
filled in up here at the top
now
what you need to do make sure your ATM
make sure you have chart Trader enabled
okay make sure you choose the ATM that
you're going to use this is my mes 13 by
what is that 26. click this up here
where it says select the valid so make
sure this name is the same as the name
over here
now this is I'm in playback mode so
account is playback make sure the same
account matches up here playback
playback I'll use the auto mode so I'm
going to change this where it says off
this is going to be automatic okay
now since I'm in playback mode okay I'm
going to run the playback here
uh
okay it should start running
faster what am I at 8X that's kind of
slow so I'm starting this on what the
17th
showing you a couple
of days so let's just speed it up here
because some playback after all so you
can see what the daily p l is
what the last trade is going to be okay
so it's kind of quick
so it's there you see it took one trade
then there was a short that came in so
it got short
you can see it running already you know
if I put it to 500 it's about fast
enough
okay so it's been a couple trades so far
all right last trade 17 daily p l is at
minus five right now
[Music]
but again you know it's up to you to set
what your uh ATM is going to be
um you know what your your stop is going
to be what your take profit is going to
be now me personally
I like to watch the order flow in
addition to just getting in and leaving
the stop or take profit in I like to
manage the trades you know I don't trade
100 different markets so I don't need to
have this thing running
um
all the time right you know like I could
sit there and I could manage the trades
right I like I trade order flows I like
to watch what the order flow is doing
and if it starts going against me or if
I see the order flow changing rather
than going and stopping me out I just
get out of the trade right there's
nobody putting a gun to your head that
says oh you know what you have to let
the trade go to your target or you have
to let it go to your take profit you
know what if the order flow starts
changing that's your sign to you know
get out of the trade basically
so you can see here how it's how it's
running
um
you know so far since midnight up till
eight o'clock it's trading the micros
the mes it's what 36 bucks again the
micros is a very small contract
so again you know I'm using my my stop
is 13 ticks my take profit is uh
26 ticks okay
so obviously I got stopped out there
so if I
have a loop I get stopped out at the
full stop you know it's like 16 bucks
but if it goes to my take profit it's
like 31 bucks so you see it got two stop
outs uh in a row
so I'm back down to just five dollars
order filmed order filmed
so
you see is there somewhere and I have a
short but then a long signal will come
in so it'll just it'll exit the trade
and get you into the new trade
whoops sorry I dropped my phone because
you're wondering that was I didn't like
fall over
um
Okay so
uh where are we at right now so time is
it it's 12 30 it's up about 100 bucks in
the micros the mes
now granted you know this was on Monday
the um 18th you know which was a nice uh
a nice nice Trends up and down
I know late in the day if you remember
on Monday
um we had that monster move up on the
close basically
but this is you know going up until two
o'clock you know it's up trading micros
196 bucks now granted not every day is
going to be like that I wish every day
is going to be like that someday's gonna
have losing days
some days you're gonna have small
winning days some days have small losing
day some days you're going to have
bigger losing days you know trading is
it's like sports sometimes it all
sometimes averages out
okay so here you see that it's got that
nice big move up
um late in the day
okay so you know I'll end it there it's
four o'clock in the afternoon so you can
see how easy it is to set up in markers
and get running right this whole video
so far is not even 10 minutes long it's
like 9 Minutes 57 seconds and a lot of
it was just showing it in replay to set
it up just literally took a couple of
minutes it's very simple uh steps to
follow so
um you know if you enjoyed this video
right
um you know just hit the like button
right I'll be happy to create more
videos just let me know if there's
something you want to see
um be sure to subscribe to the channel
so when I post new new videos on the
channel you'll get the notifications to
see them
um that's what keeps me doing this uh
making these videos so have a great day
everyone now you understand how to use
markers from the indicator store with
um the order flows Delta scalper
bye-bye